وبمقابل هذا الدعم الغربي لكيف اعلنت
موسكو الزج بالمقاتل الوعد او الروبوت
ماركر الى الحرب في اوكرانيا وهي من
الخطوات طبعا المتسارعه التي باتت تتخذها
موسكو مؤخرا عبر الدفع بالاسلحه الذكيه
الروبوت القتاليه ماركر اختبر كنظام امان
لقاعده
الفضائيه ما يوفر التحكم في محيطها الامني
اما الان فسيكون هناك العديد من الروبوتات
ماركر في منطقه التماس في دومباس تحديدا
وعن مواصفات هذا المقاتل الواعد او
الروبوت الذكي مشاهدينا فهو عباره عن مجمع
عن تقني الي بوزن نحو ثلاثه اطنان همم
يمكن ان يزود يزود باسلحه
مختلفه بما في ذلك انظمه الدفاع الجوي
القصيره المدى ويتميز الروبوت بيخفه
الحركه الذاتيه حيث يستطيع التعرف على
الاهداف لا سيما الجويه منها عادا على
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي كما يستطيع
ايضا تحديد اهداف العدو من مسافه 15 كلم
وكذلك تحديد اولوياته بحيث يستهدف مهاجمي
العدو في منطقه الهزيمه بنيرانه الخاصه
ويتمتع مشاهدينا ماركر برؤيه تقنيه ونظام
تحكم الي ويعمل بشكل مستقل في ظروف الحرب
السبرانيه والهجمات باستخدام موجات
الراديو ويؤدي مهامه القتليه بشكل مستقل
وقد تم اختبار ماركر اثناء اداء مهام خفر
منشات البنيه تحتيها الفضائيه وخفر
المطارات حيث استخدم لاكتشاف كل ما يحاول
اختراق واشتياز المناطق المراد حراستها
والتعرف عليهم والحيلوله دون وقوع هجمات
ارهابيه ومكافحه طبعا المسيره
[موسيقى]